here are some of the photographs we
never seem to delete from our phone
pictures of your pet or your parents bad
lying and uncomfortable but cute places
a photo taken in a dressing room when
you texted someone should I buy this a
series of nearly identical pictures of a
landscape or rainbows you want to print
out but never will a picture of some
notes that were important at the time
and you're now afraid to get rid of
cloud porn that you shot from an
airplane window blurry pictures from a
concert that match how blurry you were
at the time they were taken one picture
of a bad sunburn one picture of a
sunrise you sent to someone to brag that
you were awake that early a picture from
a time when you needed a quote-unquote
good picture that is not good and quite
awkward a cool looking picture of a
shadow that is only cool looking to you
one braggy picture of how good your
seats were at a sporting event one
product you wanted to price compare on
Amazon a photo of food you made that you
thought look like restaurant food you
know it didn't taste like it a photo of
something that you were trying to sell
on eBay and were amazed when some creepy
guy bought it a bunch of accidental
phone screenshots which is kind of
amazing because you don't really know
how to take them on purpose one picture
of an injury that kind of made you feel
like a badass a picture of a beer you
sent to someone to make them jealous one
or two pictures of a sign that you
thought was funny and might someday
share on tumblr your mom a picture of a
wine bottle you wanted to remember and
subsequently found out that you can't
afford a picture of your bald spot this
only applies if you are balding weird
misspellings of your name by someone in
the service industry some random shot
you never seem to delete that one pic
that you always have to swipe by quickly
when you're showing other people your
pictures a couple inanimate objects that
look kind of like people a nature shot
that looks like a heart a picture of
something kind of pathetic that you made
for someone you love
close-ups of insects close-ups of
flowers some sort of a weather event
that you just had to tell someone about
1 billion pictures of someone else's
baby that you swore you would send to
them but never will an old picture of a
friend where their hair is different and
they look
younger and happier and that makes you
feel older and love them even more and
one picture of someone who is no longer
in your life but you missed them very
much how many did you have and which
ones did I miss